this equation this one here that we
started of the day when I gave it to you
and then I'll answer questions of you
what we did was you said okay if we can
get into this form down here which we
call what again you can call on wipers
mx4 things will come and see you can
call it slope intercept form cuz that's
what that the intercept you can also
call it gradient intercept Poloncarz
brevis another slope so we saw that
going in that direction was useful it
gives you these features about the line
you don't even have to graph it you can
just look at the numbers however on
occasion you will be give it away in
this form and actually you've got to go
inverse now here's what's weird it's not
immediately obvious why this form at the
top is useful you actually have to do a
bit of work to get there
however because eventually you will they
give this by its own me they call it and
beautiful now 5x minus 2y percent equals
0 is exactly written in general form I
want to tell you the three
characteristics that make it general
firstly the right hand side do you see
what it's equal to
it's a good ear that's the first point
of thing he's been
the right hand side of the zero that's
the first important thing just like in
this form the left hand side equals one
so look at that
that's your first thing with secondly
being fancy words opponent before but
let me reintroduce it coefficients
coefficients means these numbers here
that are attached to the perennials and
this guy here as well okay
these guys do you notice they're all
whole numbers right those fractions
unlike this MX plus B form thing so up
you're looking for these whole numbers
it's okay clear negative C how about a
letter stood in there so only call those
numbers whole numbers the negatives okay
we call it integers so the coefficients
are all integers if you get given
something like this that you've
rearranged stuff so the right hand side
equals zero you're not quite a general
form yet unless everything is whole
numbers positive minus or okay there's
one last important feature up above here
you might want to rewrite essentially
you've got X's and Y's and then you've
got an extra number floating around okay
in other words every single one has this
format this is what makes general form
general form right inside zero a B and C
there are all numbers and you wrote your
X's their wives and then the constant
number okay if you call these three days
of a B and C what you want is a to be
positive series babies don't have to be
able to kind of make everything nicer
and neater it also means if you meet all
these conditions that if you go to
general fall and your friend next to you
also against the general form you will
have things that look exactly identical
as opposed to for instance you don't
need to write this I could rewrite this
equation meaning the first two
conditions but not the third I'm going
to multiply everything by negative one
watch what happens then you inspire that
so plus 2y what concepts
- 10 equals 0 the right hand sides to 0
everything using integers that's ok but
your general form and my general form
might look different as a bit weird we
want some consistency among that helps
us communicate more clearly so therefore
we add on this last condition if you
need all three of those if I give all of
you alone which I'm about to do right
now we'll all end up on exactly the same
general form so here's an example I'm
going to give you a live we're going to
convert so I'm going to give you one
like this just now okay
similar to this okay so one by one I
want the right hand side to be 0 so
that's the first thing I'm going to
start to work out there stuff on the
right hand side I want to get all of it
over on the left
so what shall I do I should subtract all
of this stuff from both sides so you can
see I'm going to get let's see - why -
this - is it was 0 some looking at my
little dot points mr. Deranian type
equals 0 check but I'm not meeting the
second one coefficients are all integers
which ones they on one out
yeah ok then one integer so what do I do
to this to change it or what if the
integers right now it isn't to get rid
of refraction I will multiply to you by
something the denominators 7 so I'll
multiply everything by 7
cy is going to come
I'll get to the negative the second if
I'm going to one step at a time
the - 407 X will become minus 4x what
about this much one and I know this
doesn't change the value but I just
personally like to write seven times
zero rivet down the right-hand side it
doesn't change that it's still gonna be
zero but a lot of people like when it's
gotten zero forget that the right-hand
side there then like I just multiply it
stuff on the left and I just forgot
there were other things then tells me
remember I multiply every single object
no exceptions by the number I chose so
have a look right hand side so Europe
introduced looks good a which number is
a in this case now I'm going to come
back over here I haven't got the auto
right have I the a is a number attached
to X at the moment that's not just 4 is
minus 4 you see that and I don't really
want that so now I'm going to multiply
everything through not just by 7 5
negative 1
okay so watch this this is going to
become negative this is going to become
positive
this is also positive it's going to be
Rho so he's still doing now I'll just
put them in the right order
exercise alphabetical yeah 4x minus 14y
1 7 and we all have the same general
form should all be identical so we've
got consistency among us so we were
comparing line you can actually start
off with something different
and end up at the same general form
which is really not so we know we've got
the right up